[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 21 juin
avec évidemment ce soir la fête de la
musique de nombreux événements sont
prévus sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et dans le reste du
département
nous serons dans quelques minutes on
direct de montigny le bretonneux avec
notre journaliste camille lambert pour
faire un point sur cette soirée qui
s'annonce festive et brûlante
un point également sur le plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines organisée ce matin un séminaire
pour notamment anticiper les évolutions
législatives en matière d'urbanisme et
répondre aussi aux interrogations des
élus sur ce document cadre et fondateur
enfin mort pas fait c'est à 50 ans
cinquante ans au sein de la 1000
nouvelles animations et expositions
étaient au rendez-vous d'une journée
festive pour mettre aussi à l'honneur
les bâtisseurs de la commune du soleil
et de la chaleur pour ce premier jour de
l'été un jour marqué aussi par
l'habituel fête de la musique de
nombreuses villes de l'agglomération
organise ce soir des concerts et on
retrouve camille lambert et patrick
jacques de dixmude en direct de montigny
le bretonneux devant le muy med bonsoir
à tous les deux camille les festivités
ne vont pas tarder à commencer à
montigny n est ce pas bonsoir nicolas
oui tout à fait alors ça même
c'est dès ce midi en fait en partenariat
avec la médiathèque du canal et le
conservatoire des arts les visiteurs ont
déjà pu assister à quelques temps forts
alors là pourtant dû sûrement derrière
moi les derniers réglages sont en train
de se préparer car ici dans une petite
heure maintenant sur le quai du imed sur
lequel françois truffaut que giroud pour
se produire jusqu'à 23h minuit et 19h30
alors on a peut-être quelques problèmes
de liaison on essaiera de vous retrouver
tout à l'heure camille mais de nombreux
événements je vous le disais sont
organisées à montigny le bretonneux
également dans les yvelines
rendez vous et éventuellement sur les
sites internet des mairies pour plus
d'informations et si vous sortez ce soir
pensez à vous protéger et à boire de
l'eau météo france maintient son alerte
orange canicule pour la région
francilienne cette nuit les températures
vont dépasser facilement les 20° demain
la journée sera encore très chaude les
températures devraient dépasser cette
fois ci les 30 degrés dès la fin de la
matinée pensez donc aussi à appeler vos
proches les plus fragiles et pour plus
d'information vous pouvez également
contacter le numéro d'urgence suivant le
0 800 06 66 66 et autre conséquence de
cette chaleur la pollution à l'ozone
s'installe sur la région pour inciter
les franciliens à utiliser les
transports en commun le stif proposa
proposera jeudi un tarif spécial de 3
euros 80 et celui ci devrait connaître
un certain succès puisque est la
circulation elle sera interdite demain
entre 5h30 et minuit pour tous les
véhicules qui ont une vignette critères
quatre ou cinq dont le périmètre à
l'intérieur de l'a86 c'est-à-dire paris
et la proche banlieue
l'actualité de ce mercredi marquée aussi
par les premiers soubresauts du
quinquennat emmanuel macron ce matin
françois bayrou et marielle de sarnez
tous deux membres du modem du modem ont
annoncé qu'ils quittaient le
gouvernement sur fond d' enquête sur les
assistants parlementaires européens
écoutez à ce propos la réaction du
nouveau député des yvelines et président
du modem 78 bruno myle yens selon lui à
rien ne changera malgré ces démissions
écoutez le pour que l'on arrête de faire
des amalgames
il ya un accord de majorité
présidentielle qui a été conclu bien
avant le premier tour des élections
présidentielles entre le modèle et la
république en marche
d'accord cet accord court toujours et
continuera à courir cette majorité
présidentielle
elle est sur ses deux pieds le modem
d'un côté la république en marche était
la volonté du président de la république
et ça reste la communauté ça reste on
est un travail pour le projet lui
présent la république parce que ça nous
paraît être le seul projet qui vaille
pour sortir la france du marasme au
canada voilà et dans le reste de
l'actualité locale à saint quentin en
yvelines la mise en place du plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal se poursuit
avec une problématique à régler
désormais l'arrivée de cinq nouvelles
communes l'an passé ce matin un
séminaire était organisé justement pour
répondre aux questions de ses nouvelles
vies de ces nouvelles villes concernées
par le p lui lé précision avec ce
reportage de camille lambert aménager un
territoire à 12 communes en fonction des
problématiques de chacun c'est le défi
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines lancé en
le plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal
paix et lui a été dévoilé aux cinq
nouvelles villes entrées en 2016 dans la
communauté d'agglomération on voit bien
que chaque commune à des projets
d'aménagement donc c'est comment on fait
pour les articuler puisqu'un projet
d'aménagement nécessairement des
conséquences sur la vie la côte et en
général en terme de circulation ne
serait-ce que ça donc ça oblige je
dirais les communes à travailler
ensemble pour poser leurs preuves de
leurs projets d'aménagement
on vit pas seul dans son coin il faut
qu'on partage avec avec ce qu'il ya
autour coignières les clayes-sous-bois
maurepas plaisir et villepreux ont
participé à un séminaire pour comprendre
les enjeux de ce pays et lui quelles
zones seront urbanisés
quels logements seront construits et
quels espaces verts seront préservés
voilà quelques problématiques abordées
les choisit venir à ce séminaire parce
qu'en fait la commune de coignières est
en cours d'élaboration de son plan local
d'urbanisme est donc être ici ça permet
d'en savoir plus sur les plans locaux
d'urbanisme et à terme les plans locaux
d'urbanisme intercommunaux ce genre de
journée permet d'échanger avec les
autres communes pour partager les
expériences pour voir ce qu'on a en
commun ce qu'on a de différent
une cinquantaine d'élus et d'agents des
douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient présents un premier
séminaire qui pourrait être suivi
d'autres rencontres du même type 50 en
cinq ans 50 en plus tôt excusez moi avec
saint quentin en yvelines justement là
et le lapsus c'est un événement et qui
se fait la ville de maurepas organisé
pour l'occasion de grande journée
festive au programme des animations du
soleil et beaucoup de souvenirs le fil
de cette journée avec nicolas landry et
charline hurel les mort patience août au
rendez vous pour fêter les 50 ans de la
ville des bribes de photographies
retracent l'histoire de maurepas sur la
plage à cri bout du chantier de la poste
commencé en 1972 à l'école de la
marnière les souvenirs rejaillissent
c'est avec une pointe d'émotion et
beaucoup dé fierté que le maire rigault
et christian couvre l'événement tant est
que je suis mort patients de naissance
voilà j'aime ma ville et voilà je je
trouve que son urbanisme sa conception
est une très bonne chose est une très
belle réussite
et en plus de pouvoir accueillir à ce
50e anniversaire l'architecte de
maurepas le fils du promoteur monsieur
riboud et
le sculpteur pour la première fois
réunis sur un événement comme celui là
voilà c'est un honneur pour moi tout est
pensé pour que chacun sa mise sous un
soleil de plomb les enfants profitent
des jouets gonflables installées pour
l'occasion
pendant que les adultes eux échangent
autour d'un repas tout en ostalgie ça
vous rappelle tous les souvenirs du
début puisque je suis là depuis 1970 69
donc j'ai vu toute évolution de des
différents sites qui sont indiqués sur
le sur ces photos quoi moi ça me fait
bizarre parce que j'ai vu mon ancienne
école et
elle a beaucoup changé
[Musique]
des jeux que je connaissais pas des
endroits où je
tous les jours
qui change
il faut savais pas que c'était comme ça
la journée prend fin et se termine sur
une dernière note de musique
un événement qui sera pour sûr un
souvenir de plus pour les morlaisiens du
côté de montigny le bretonneux les
travaux de rénovation du sud canal sont
enfin terminés après plusieurs mois de
chantier pour l'inauguration hier était
organisée une summer party plusieurs
personnalités de la ville étaient
présentes pour l'occasion haussmann
vendeurs d et stéphane servant ils
étaient une cinquantaine de personnes
réunies hier place etienne marcel au
centre commercial sud kannad de
montigny-le-bretonneux
parmi eux le maire de la commune michel
laugier plutôt satisfait du résultat
on a passé des périodes qui était que
dès que ben difficile et donc
commercialiser l'ensemble des surfaces
société un petit peu compliqué nous y
sommes arrivés
en plus aujourd'hui il ya des travaux
d'investissements importants qui ont été
réalisés on voit bien aujourd'hui toutes
les coques commercial son plein il ya
une nouvelle dynamique il ya aussi de
nouvelles de signalétique
c'est à la suite du départ du magasin
bricorama qu'après une longue réflexion
des travaux ont été entrepris le but
morcelé cette grande surface pour avoir
plus d'animations ils ont fait un gros
lifting le propriétaire a souhaité
investir enfin sur le design
et sûr
la manière d'accueillir les clients
voilà il fallait faire de façon à un
gros coup de de renouvellement de nos
façades ont c'est chose faite
il fallait intégrer des nouveaux
commerces c'est chose faite sous voilà
donc maintenant on parle assure 1.0 de
revivre vitalité d'une sans conversion
aujourd'hui sur cette place vous
retrouverez une salle de sport un
magasin de détail et en commerce de
jouets pour enfants dysport à présent et
du sport pour la bonne cause en
l'honneur de maele une jeune barbadienne
atteinte de leucémie un gala de basket
était organisée dimanche par le club
local vous le voyez à l'image le public
était au rendez vous entre dribbler
entracte rythmée par de la danse tout
était pensé pour sortir mail de son
quotidien comme nous l'expliquent une
joueuse du club de mort pas écouté la
journée festive et on a voulu associer
sa voix là avec une petite cagnotte une
petite entrée participative à partir de
1 euro
histoire ben voilà que la somme qui sera
récoltée la famille pour en disposer
comme elle veut
et vraiment les aider à passer des
moments meilleur dans cette épreuve
qu'est la maladie
on est de tout coeur derrière la famille
de mails derrière ma el mahi cnt notre
fille aussi donc on est de tout coeur
avec elle et on retrouve désormais
camille lambert devant le muy m'aide à
montigny le bretonneux tout à l'heure on
était coupé camille vous ne faisiez un
point sur sur les festivités pour cette
fête de la musique
déjà alors au nom d'une petite heure
matin sur le parvis de lui-même sur le
quai françois truffaut plusieurs
groupements se produire jusqu'à 23h
minuit avant d'entonner dernièrement ils
sont déjà en transcendant balança de
répéter pour eux le soir et donc des dix
rencontres la formation audoise et
pierre qui vire à le ballon ne pas
croire que j'ai gagné une des dernière
édition du tremplin musical de la ville
sont chauds et en ce moment ils
enregistrent leur premier recul dans le
studio de mondes s'ignorent
en conséquence le groupe a hélas ceux
qui répètent ce sont la villa aimerait
donc à 22h08 a pris ce texte remonte sur
les planches guitariste bassiste et
pianiste batteur et saxophoniste en
véritable orchestre ils ont préparé un
répertoire sous peu terne 165 exemple
vous ont repris notamment
[Musique]
et nul doute qu ici malgré la chaleur
les téléspectateurs vont très
certainement
docile ce qu'être à danser sur des
rythmes endiablés alors ça c'est pour
montigny le bretonneux huckabee
expliquez-nous un peu le programme
peut-être pour les yvelines assez
rapidement
alors j'entends pas très bien nicolas
donc je suppose qu'à lancer son réseau
ses vêtements dans les yvelines parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup et qui sera
organisée la également à maurepas depuis
10h ce matin toute la ville résonne une
rançon de nombreuses formations et en ce
moment se dit y ait un tout
gianni de la place au moins jusqu'à 22h
et dans un autre style à 21h
l'association les routes et sa danse
orientale au coudray à bassenge
contourner ça commence
est ce grand rendez-vous dans l'album
laisse passer une dizaine d'artistes
alterneront sur scène et enfin un
dernier rendez vous il y en a beaucoup
moins pas tout c'est super mais ces
covers rampe à 21h à quoi partie le
groupe de reprises de supertramp en
santé un petit point que je pense
le groupe de reprises de supertramp le
seul qui existe en france il a été
acclamé par l'une des plus grandes voix
de la formation mythique des années 70
80 rodger hodgson et son saxophoniste
donc six musiciens français 1 pour nous
faire redécouvrir les plus grands titres
de supertramp comme breakfast in america
ledit caleçon ou encore goodbye stranger
donc à ne pas manquer c'est dans la cour
de la ferme de la tramblais merci cali
lambert avec patrick jacques de dixmude
pour toutes ces précisions pour la fête
de la musique
amusez vous bien si vous sortez ce soir
c'est la fin de ce journal tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver sur tv fil
78 points comme ou l'application tv fil
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]